no this isn't the beginning of an MGM
movie this is an African lion announcing
to the world that he is the king of
beasts other animals may dispute this
but if they do they probably keep it to
themselves
of course the Lions kingdom used to be
one heck of a lot bigger North America
South America Europe Africa and Asia now
their ever shrinking domain is down to
just parts of two continents Africa and
a small number that live in the gear
forests of Northwest India unlike a lot
of cats lions will hang out together up
to 40 lions make up what's called a
pride
the male's stake out their charter fire
roaring and scent-marking
oh and by the way when a lion bellows
animals five miles away can hear it too
someone's when it comes to hunting the
females do the lion's share in addition
to raising the young ones and besides
all that duty they're busy having Cubs
every two years they just ate for three
and a half months then give birth to
anywhere from one to five cups the
carnivorous Cubs start eating meat just
three months after birth unfortunately
the Cubs are vulnerable they can die of
starvation when food is scarce and if
the dominant male of the pride is killed
a new dominant male will kill all the
Cubs
no wonder up to 80% of all lion cubs
never make it to their third year of
life
if they can avoid being eaten themselves
they like to dine on jumbo portions like
caramel zebras and wildebeests except
when they come upon something so exotic
they simply can't resist like these
ostrich eggs
now here's an animal that can kill an e2
zebra but can't crack an egg so go
figure
life is a lion isn't all hunting and
mating and roaring it also involves one
heck of a lot of sleeping
truth be told Lions are only on their
paws for about 4 to 5 hours a day the
rest of the day they're resting with 19
to 20 hours of nap time the habitat of
lions is shriveled and threatens to
shrivel more if the domain of the lion
isn't preserved this marvellous beast
and its neighbors might be lost measures
are being taken but vigilance is still
required don't take it from me let's let
the Lions speak for themselves
[Music]